Have you thought any more
about offline access?
>> Mm-hm.
>> I'm just thinking about the gift
shopping I'll be doing during my
vacation in Hawaii.
I'm not sure how my cell network
access is going to be out there and
it'd be really good to not lose
all my shopping list data when
the internet connection is flaky.
>> Well.
>> Well,
I guess it's a fair point but,
I don't know the more you think about it
the more tricky it sounds
like it be to set up.
So first of all you need to be caching
the data locally somewhere which would
necessitate using maybe a SQL-like
database or something like that.
You'd also be needing to cache kind
of the stuff that the user does when
the app is offline.
So say you were to buy.
I don't know some tiki masks or
something offline.
You would then need to send
that data that you bought that
to the phone when you reconnect.
And frankly, we just don't have the
engineering resources right now to even
start implementing that.
>> Firebase is actually doing some
caching by default as well as
queuing any actions your
user makes offline.
>> Well, actually that's awesome.
In that case don't we just
get offline access for free?
>> Some of the time.
>> Okay, well.
I'm wrapped up in important
business decisions.
So maybe you can talk to the developer
about all that offline stuff.
>> Sure.
You do know your camera is on right now?
>> Yes, yes it is
>> Okay let's talk a little
about how Firebase deals with offline
access and data in general and
what you get for free.
We have two clients your phone
in my phone for example.
And let's say my phone isn't connected.
Maybe I put my phone into airplane mode.
But I still have shopping list
plus plus up on my device.
In this situation,
my client keeps a local cache.
This includes all the data that was in
the app the last time I had access.
I can keep making changes and
see them immediately.
In actuality,
every client of Firebase app maintains
its own version of active data.
And changes made for
this local copy of the database trigger
actions locally first before
data gets written to the server.
So it's not just a matter
of it works offline.
It's actually by design.
Anyway when I'm connected again,
the app will get updated based
on the changes I made offline.
In that situation my client will push
the correct events to the server,
the ones I made offline, and
I will get the changes from the server
based on the changes you made.
This is what you get for
free with Firebase.